bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors c'est visiblement
devenu une tradition estivale theresa
may en 2018 pour parler du bric site
vladimir poutine on l'a dit l'an dernier
pour tenter de réanimer la russie à
l'europe cette année donc en gala merkel
à brégançon
on sait qu emmanuel macron aime jouer
avec les symboles quel message est ce
qu'il veut faire passer là en
ressemblant en recevant la chancelière
allemande alors les réunions bilatérales
sont une tradition du couple
franco-allemand depuis le traité de
l'elysée signé par le général de gaulle
et le chancelier allemand konrad
adenauer et le président français
évidemment ce se concerte avec tous les
grands dirigeants dans le monde parce
que la france se considère comme une
puissance européenne et mondiale alors
considéré en ce qui concerne le couple
franco-allemand là la stratégie on
pourrait parler de stratégie du couple
franco allemand pour la france c'est une
stratégie de pouvoir pour montrer que
c'est le le couple franco allemand qui
est qui est à la barre qui dirige
l'union européenne qui détermine les
grands angles et les grandes
orientations et surtout pour la france
est un moyen d'essayer de montrer en
termes de communication qui a une parité
franco allemande une parité géopolitique
dans l'union européenne entre
l'allemagne et la france alors qu'en
réalité c'est l'allemagne depuis la
réunification allemande qui ans qui
occupe le centre de l'union européenne
qui est la puissance centrale
les sujets ne manquent pas notamment la
déstabilisation du pourtour de l'union
européenne le donc le mali qui est une
zone prioritaire stratégique pour la
france
la méditerranée en général le liban la
biélorussie également les relations
difficiles avec la turquie et la mise en
oeuvre du plan européen de relance pour
lutter contre les effets du coran
navires us alors on va rentrer un peu
plus dans le détail dans toutes ces
thématiques qui seront abordées à
brégançon mais pour revenir sur ce
couple franco-allemand est ce que à vaux
d'yonne a encore du sens aujourd'hui ce
qu'il existe toujours une relation
privilégiée entre paris et berlin
alors on voit bien que de toute façon
toutes les décisions européennes ne
peuvent se prendre qu'avec un accord
franco allemand
mais c'est de moins en moins suffisant
c'est à dire que les autres pays membres
sont de plus en plus irrité que ce soit
le couple franco-allemand qui décide des
affaires de l'union européenne
mais s'il n'y a pas d'accord
franco-allemand il n'y aura pas d'accord
au niveau de l'union européenne mais
aujourd'hui on voit bien que si un
accord franco-allemand cela facilite
quand même l'avancée des négociations
mais ce n'est plus suffisant et lors on
a vu lors de l'appel à la négociation
pour la mise en oeuvre du du plan de
relance européen
ça va être assez difficile parce que il
y à un accord européen mais il ya des
dissensions internes qui se cache
derrière cet accord et l'union
européenne sur une voie de fragmentation
géopolitique depuis l'unification
allemande évidemment l'allemagne est
devenue la première puissance de l'union
européenne la france a toujours essayer
de rééquilibrer la relation avec
l'allemagne mais là elle a du mal on
voit dans le plan de relance européen
est un élément qui a été totalement
escamoté c'est la disparition du budget
de la zone euro qui était une priorité
française et qui a été abandonné dans le
plan de relance ou c'est l'allemagne qui
de nouveau se replace au centre de
l'union européenne pour sauvegarder le
marché unique et on voit bien aussi les
priorités géopolitiques diffèrent la
france met l'accent sur la méditerranée
par exemple dans son cas de
confrontation avec la turquie pour
soutenir la grèce l'allemagne à une
position plus neutre parce que elle a
des relations plus fortes avec la
turquie et regarde vers l'est sa
priorité aussi à la stabilisation
l'occidentalisation delà du flanc
oriental de l'union européenne dans une
approche euro atlantistes et là aussi il
peut y avoir des différences parce que
les désagréments effectivement toute
mésentente sur ce sujet avec berlin mais
enfin concernant l'attitude de la
turquie en méditerranée mais les
divergences sont très forte alors
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que ça représente
le couple franco allemand
aux yeux de l'allemagne alors pour
l'allemagne le
franco allemand n'est pas une relation
privilégiée l'allemagne de plus en plus
des relations bilatérales avec la
pologne les états unis la chine tous les
pays du monde et l'allemagne considèrent
que la relation franco allemande est une
relation misa sur un pied d'égalité avec
les relations avec les autres états
membres de l'union européenne et les
grands états de ce monde tandis que pour
la france c'est une relation privilégiée
la france aimerait avoir une un couple
franco-allemand au sommet de l'union
européenne justement pour essayer de
placer la france à parité avec
l'allemagne donc la france est
demandeuse vis-à-vis d'allemagne tandis
que l'allemagne qui est au centre de
l'union européenne considère la france
plus comme un partenaire normale dans
son pourtour géographique
même si la relation et reste quand même
importante depuis le depuis le traité de
l'élysée alors à châtier les gens et
progrès la survie à chaque dirigeant
étranger reçu à brégançon sa thématique
quel sujet prioritaire aujourd'hui entre
emmanuel macron et angela merkel à vos
yeux sont des sujets évidemment qui sont
sélectionnés en fonction des priorités
de l'allemagne et de la france
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure pour la
france c'est évidemment le coup d'état
au mali la déstabilisation du sahel la
relation avec la turquie et la
méditerranée
la relation avec la grèce il y a aussi
le liban ça ce sont des priorités pour
la france tandis que pour l'allemagne ce
sera le plus tôt la biélorussie la
déstabilisation du flanc oriental la
relation avec la russie et pour les deux
partenaires sur un pied d'égalité je
voudrais dire c'est le le la mise en
oeuvre du plan de relance européen après
la crise du grenat virus parce qu'il
faut encore ratifié l'accord par les
parlements nationaux ce qui ne sera pas
une mince affaire et donc ccc sommet
franco-allemand donc mon truc parité que
le
le couple franco allemand est au sommet
du pouvoir dans l'union européenne
mais derrière ce couple évidemment se
cachent des priorités géopolitiques
différentes et une relation asymétrique
de plus en plus prononcé entre
l'allemagne la france ou c'est
l'allemagne notamment aussi depuis le
break site qui prend l'ascendant le plus
en plus dans les négociations
merci beaucoup pour votre éclairage
pierre-emmanuel un taux mann consultant
en géopolitique et fondateur du site
internet euros continent